people
okay
foreign
[Music]
set out before us item one apologies for
absence yes chair we've received
apologies from councilor em Foster who's
been substituted by councilor S Club
we've also received apologies from
councilor L hartzon who substituted by
councilor T Lacey thank you chair thank
you moving on to item two Declarations
of Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests not already on their register
of interests in any item on the agenda
and withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time do we have any interest
to declare
um oh yes I just like it that I hold the
portfolio for looks a Cabinet member
um and therefore
um it is within to a degree within my
scope of Interest however
um Junior interests
um and have made no comment up to this
point at any time thank you
are there any other interests to declare
yeah
thank you thank you item three minutes
of the last meeting we now have the
minutes of family
February this year are we all happy that
they are electrical thank you thank you
just a show of hands
that's everybody thank you the motion
has been carried we can now move on to
the main business
so do applications in the TPO but before
I start I would like not to explain
on YouTube how we deal with them
yes thank you chair
this is the proceed considering the
business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments okay
Seasons the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting
they will each be given three minutes to
put forward their views
they'll be reminded given by the clerk
when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
question
in order to clarify any points that they
have made
after the speaker has addressed the
kitty and answered any questions then
they will be allowed to remain in the
meeting but they will not be allowed to
participate further from this point
the chair will then open the meeting for
questions to officers
a debate by the committee of opening the
application by a vote
the vote will be taken by roll call
finally members being live streamed and
according will be made which will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you moving on to the first
application which is Ned
was Slash
200574 forward slash FFL at holmesfield
to tell us about any links but I'm sure
you've all seen them on table and to
give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site
I will allow the officers to complete
the presentation consequently members
could you please reserve any points or
order or questions until the end thank
you
thank you chair
I'm going to go through a brief
introduction here and then go through
the slides that we've prepared for
members but firstly just to ask members
to note the late comments report as
you've said was issued yesterday in the
late comments in respect of the homes
field application
the application chair seats consent to
use a field located to the south of
homesfield for dog exercise and training
it lies in the green belt in an area of
multiple environmental sensitivity
facilities
on the existing access create a limited
parking and turning area and correct
1.86 meters high and closing the field
but set back in from the field margins
members will need to assess if the
proposal is acceptable development in
this location in this context and
adequately protects the amenity of the
nearest Residential Properties
members should also note that the
highway Authority environmental health
officers in the Derbyshire Wildlife
trust do not object in principle to the
application
sure the committee will also note yeah
that officers are recommending a
temporary permission be granted for a
limited two-year period that's in line
with the environmental health officer
advice that we've received and it offers
the chance for the use to begin but a
time period to test that it can operate
in the proposed and in an acceptable way
this conclusion does impact on some
elements of the scheme chair should it
be guaranteed consent in this form
including the initial servicing of the
car parking area and Landscaping they
could be reassessed following the expiry
of any temporary permission at the end
of that two-year period
on the chair in reviewing the proposed
conditions officers actually considered
that conditions 7 9 and 10 which require
further details to be submitted are not
actually proportionate to the granting
of a temporary permission and in the
case of the highway conditions are
otherwise encapsulated within the terms
and conditions which would otherwise be
conditioned that's the ecological
requirements could be adequately
safeguarded and required at any time in
the future if a permanent consent was
granted they are therefore not
considered necessary by officers at this
point
just go through the the slides chair
further to the the site visit that we
undertook yesterday virtually
and the the first slide chair just shows
the the site
outlined in in beige at the center of
the slide as you can see at the northern
Point Northwestern point is the access
to millthorpe Lane which they access
onto the highway Network and then as you
can see the site extends from there in
the southerly direction and generally
downhill
thanks Alice
the second slide shares the site
outlined in red and if we can just go on
to the next
slider shows the area where the fencing
would be erected as I say set in from
the field margin through height that
would keep out and deer and other
um species that might otherwise get in
and and go into the field and then it's
connected to the car parking area at the
top end of the field you can see the
nearest properties that are referred to
in the report chair to the North
comprising holmesfield Village and then
there is another property again referred
to in the report just off to the
Southwest the as the nearest property to
the Southwest beyond that the field are
joining the site
thanks Alice
and these two slides chair put together
show on the right hand side the new
access the position of the gate set back
from the access point and the car
parking and turning area along with the
initially limited landscaping that's
proposed and then the slide on the left
shows the gapping that's referred to in
the committee report additional trees
that would be planted again we'll see a
snippet of those in the photographs but
we did see how that would work yesterday
and there's just some photographs to
share just to remind members of what we
saw yesterday this is the existing
access point with the gate and the area
to the left of the gate would be in the
long term if consent were granted and
then a permanent permission granted
would be Wildflower Meadow and planting
area the area in the foreground beyond
the gate is where the parking and
turning areas would be formed
thanks at least
this is the the view from the access
point to the north towards holmesfield
and then the next slide should ideally
be South along Mill thought Lane to the
the South
thanks Alice
I think there's this is um looking back
towards the the site access which is
just where the little van on the left
hand side of the photograph is is just
at that point there and then this shows
the nearest residential property and the
out building that's referred to in some
detail in the report chair otherwise the
site in the foreground is a field
thank you
moving on to our speakers and we'll take
them in order
with the ward member councilor Bentley
Stafford Stevenson to speak first if
you'd like to take a seat
with three minutes when you're ready
thank you chair good afternoon committee
members and colleagues
I called in this application on the
basis of the strength of feeling amongst
the local community never in my time as
a local counselor or a resident of
holmesfield have I seen such a
controversial application in which so
many residents are in opposition as
you'll have seen in the pack there are
73 objections and 77 letters of support
of the 77 letters all bar two are from
outside the local area such as Clay
Cross and even from outside of Northeast
Derbyshire as far away as Rotherham I do
not believe that people will travel that
distance to use a dog walking facility
and a quick Google search brings up
several walking areas already in
existence
much closer to those residences websites
such as dog walkingfields.com provides a
map of local facilities and there are
existing sites listed in Matlock
silkstone Barnsley and two in
Chesterfield alone it's also worth
pointing out that there's already a dog
training facility on the border of
Barlow and dropfield Hilltop making
another similar facility in the area
inappropriate Village there's no
economic social or aesthetic benefit to
local residents and whilst the ambition
started
it's a new business it's their own local
employers live within my Water
Production is not welcome or appropriate
and I'm sure there are better sites
elsewhere not within Greenbelt and there
are many reasons for objections stated
within the pack and I don't think there
will be demand from local residents for
the facility and I failed to see how it
will bring in further Revenue to the
local economy as people will be driving
in parking up and driving out
Council tourism and Leisure but this
development will have the opposite
effect in section 6.4 within the pack
outlining the five purposes of Greenbelt
albeit development is not created in the
scope of the outpatient the objective to
preserve the setting and especially
would be detrimental to the special
Crown Within
but
this stop
and attracts people from The Wider area
whereas bucolic and tranquil landscape
horse riding and the reason why many
residents choose to I do not use that
word and proceed to go into a local
Purple Cafe particularly if the dog has
behavioral issues and this is a farming
community and it's my intention right
for it to remain so the overwhelming
illness on the applicant police noise
nuisance pollution access and security
when they will not be present
despite
Assurance from the applicant for this to
happen bringing down behavior issues
Into the Heart of a livestock farming
Community is like bringing a tetra
to bonfire to be included 30 seconds is
described why I start deer fencing
almost two meters high I don't believe
this contributes to high quality design
as per the sdc-12 planning policy and
does the will of local the government
one planning decision is to be in the
hands of local communities yet this
application become an applicant from
outside of the area is completely
attached with this intention I therefore
come in the committee to reject the
planning application
the wishes and concerns of the actual
local residents thank you chair thank
you committee thank you are there any
questions
councilor Hall
yeah hi yeah good afternoon I was just
going to ask you uh a few when they say
talk about dog exercise and Training
Facility may or may not be all time so
but I just wanted to know when when
talking about a turning Circle for cars
and people coming from outside the area
so what the idea of it is for someone to
get in the car put the car at the dog in
the car I'll drive to this facility and
and
that take it for a walk and then take
proposal is or is there or explaining
you through it or is it it's going to be
overnight in kennels you know a bit more
about them please the idea from the
application was being received is that
anybody wanting to use the site would
essentially have to start which is why
there's a limited number of car parking
spaces and supposedly to avoid the
number of community traffic on the road
number of the development itself of the
car park and so on so it would be time
slots yes the idea is that with the
fencing which is you know almost
there are the two
yeah I'm sure offices when you get to it
can provide a little bit more detail on
the commissions and the
scope
Council around
this is not going to be
an open again and it can go off into
farmland and do as it feels whether it
you know wants to buy to sheep or not
which we don't allow
have you got proof that there's you know
that the dogs would be able to get out
do you know of any bad behaved jokes
there are bad babe dogs and the whole
point of this is for Behavioral issues
as well as dogs to remain free of the
lead
one instance of that to happen I care
for the farmers in my community we have
sheep on my farm alone and sheep
worrying is a major concern uh you
probably hear it in the general news so
I can't guarantee that it Willow won't
happen who can guarantee that well I
can't guarantee that if they do get out
that it may happen then you know things
of what will happen with that with
Farmers coming across a dog that's
running Australia so
there's a likelihood of it I can't
guarantee it or won't happen but the
point is it's a drug training facility
you know if there are dogs there with
behavioral problems you're increasing
the likelihood so it's it's just
exacerbating the problem that exists
right now but could exist if it was to
be granted I hear what you say but now
we spoke about a dog Conan facility and
then we spoke about people getting in
the car driving to that spot taking the
dogs walk in the car you know and
obviously driving back home or wherever
so what is it is it a Doctrine facility
or is it somewhere you can take your pet
my point is you go there your dog you
exercise them let them run through you
remain with your dog when you get in
your car and drive off my point was I
don't see any benefits the local economy
because if the dog has behavioral issues
they're not going to take it into a
local public are they or a pick your own
pumpkin patch it's going to be just
driven there and used but I fail to
believe that someone from Rotherham
about unknown Village probably to their
training facility when there's more on
their local doorstep
isn't it
it's by choice
if somebody wants to come from Rotherham
to to visit this place we can't say
where they're coming from you couldn't
tell me where they're coming from
because all we'd say was a person in a
car
or two people in a carpet you can't say
all that car's coming from another
Improvement Point by saying someone's
coming to
this
you disappear it doesn't matter where
they're from but all the letters of
support
are from outside the area bar too which
indicates at this point well either it's
a PR campaign to get encouragement
support for friends of me that may have
decided they want to support the
application or they will be the actual
users of the facility again coming from
outside of the village
in the village and as you'll see for
more glitter's objection people won't
use this we're in the middle of the
countryside we have walks on our
doorstep Farmers have their own land
they're going to use that they're not
going to use that facility there they're
already exercising their dogs where they
should need to so yes you can't please
where they're coming from but I think
that's an irrelevant Point almost the
application just shows that the strength
of support is from outside the area
again thank you you know that's that's
all I'm asking for
and thank you thank you
simple question is about Remington slot
team field who will supervise the
animals if it's a training facility I
just assume rightly or wrongly that
people will turn up with a dog they'll
be somebody their supervising something
of these animals and
I'm going to calculate
the lion bringing the dogs that they
they've been so many shook Gates how
many times have you worked in the
country to left Gates wide open for
farmers and livestock have runoff so
this comes down to how do you how do you
police it and yes the applicant has said
that they will you know check in once a
day but
it's already happened by then hasn't it
I have questions under policing for the
officers
um the the second question if you if you
don't mind here uh whose field is it is
it a local owner's field local farmers
field that the applicant is is the owner
of the field as I understand and then
but they're not resident in the village
right okay thank you
answer Armitage
thank you
uh I've noticed that uh it's good in for
dear friends and rubbish fencing at the
base uh
is there any evidence that there are
deer in the area and and rabbits
there are deer in the area we have them
on our own Farm they they what I believe
they've come from the Chatsworth estate
and they've just wandered out into the
uh the Moorland so we get them across
our land
um whether they've Venture that far into
the village itself can't say I've
personally seen it but it is there's a
chance and rabbits are everywhere yeah
so
yes to your point and uh other book
paths uh were dogs could be exercise
there are footpaths walkways Bridal
routes and obviously quiet country lanes
that you can you can walk on right thank
you
are there any further questions speaker
no thank you if you'd like to take a
seat thank you
our next speak for the afternoon is
Claire Brooks yeah sorry Joe just to
explain we will be bringing in the
speakers in uh groups simply because of
the the numbers involved so asha's just
gone to get them now and I think
there'll be a further three in this
group thank you chair
foreign
[Music]
and I've got our next speaker down with
Claire Brooks
you'd like to just state your name and
then you've three minutes when you're
ready
sorry could you use a microphone please
okay sorry
um my name is Claire Brooks I'm the
landowner of the field next door called
Brookfield Stables excuse me and the
owner of the horse
I have been a horse owner for 55 years
so there's not a lot you can tell me
about horses reactions to situations
I've been there done it got the T-shirt
um I'm also a British horse Society
access and bridalways officer for seven
years as well
um
first thing I want to address is the
boundaries of this field
um I did notice in the conditional
approval sheet or report that
um
they were talking about uh must put up a
secure boundary build rebuild the
boundaries
that boundary
between the applicant field and my field
is virtually non-existent
I have planted in my field
over 700
um Hawthorn whips so far I have got
another 300 to go in what I've actually
got on hand
um I will be planting probably another
500 on top of that
now if you drive up there you will see a
hedge going across the field that hedge
is nine years old
well I've planted whips to build rebuild
the boundary down the roadside anywhere
else where they are close to the trees
and already in existence
those are still nine years on only two
feet high
because the existing trees are taking
the water and the nutrients out of the
ground they haven't died
but they're not thriving
so that boundary is going to take
anything from 15 to 20 years of
replanting to actually become a boundary
that is going to contain animals of any
description
and it's just massive holes at the
moment
so I wanted to make that one that point
particularly clear
and the other thing I want to
um
uh to talk about is Animal Welfare
because this is what this exercise area
is all about really Animal Welfare
training the dogs those that have a
problem those that have uh that may be
nervous or 30 seconds remain
so uh those
if those dogs Escape
there's no boundary fencing to stop them
getting into my field and chasing my
horses who is going to be responsible if
my horses are critically or fatally
injured because horses are prey animals
they will run
dogs are Hunters they will chase and
attack
I'm more concerned now what's the
original application
thank you are there any questions for
the speaker
councilor Hall
thank you I'm sorry yeah it's okay I'm
over here uh I just wanted to ask when
you say you have horses in your field
which is the field oval shaped one
running down the west side on the map
sure
so that big oval one with the lines
going across that one that one just all
that thank you it's also when you talk
about uh foot paths and Bridal ways it
says in our report that there's a public
path right of way at p26 that runs to
the east of the site so that's yeah
they've got Paris actually
um it's from the top of uh cartilage
Lane and runs down
two Fields away actually from my field
so one field away from the applicant
field and it runs all the way down to
halfway
um down Mill thought Lane
right so so would you get like horses on
that you mean no that's a book pass not
allowed horses are not allowed on
footpaths okay I just wondered the
bridal paths we are allowed on and
there's a bridal path from cartilage
Lane straight down into Barlow okay and
for your field you have one horse or
several three horses at the moment
there's three I've got stables for four
but there's three at the moment okay
with stable yeah thank you
any other questions
no thank you if you'd like to take your
seat thank you and leave this on you can
do here our next speaker is Louisa
Nicholson
no okay moving on
just conferring here
it appears our speaker's list is out of
filter is Robert Barnes who I think he
did the next one sure
let's see
if you'd like to state your name and
then it's three minutes when you're
ready yes sir Robert Barnes
uh I am Robert Barnes I am fortunate to
have lived in this Valley for 58 years
I worked on local farms from the age of
12 to 25 and helped on my parents small
plant nursery so I was of the land I am
now a builder
as such I understand and know that
nothing Remains the Same and change does
happen
however not all changes for the good and
in fact some is done right detrimental
not only in a subjective way but more
importantly
in an objective and factual way namely
damaging the environment and ultimately
human health
Winston Churchill once said a healthy
population is a nation's greatest asset
back in his day at the countryside and
the food It produced was not under the
current threats as it is now
consequently I wish to endorse
and to elaborate and state a healthy
Countryside is a population's greatest
asset
by removing another several Acres of hay
Meadow
from the countryside to an unnatural use
is another blow ultimately to us all
as I stated in my original letter it is
unnatural for canines to be
canines
from many areas to be using such a
confined area in year in year out
land has evolved for a higher densities
of herbivores
and much much lower densities of canines
day nines I.E dogs are by Nature top
predators and as such
agents and susceptible to pathogens
diseases and insect-one vectors
existing diseases such as Lyme disease
and a plasma toxitis which has actually
been warned about on the Derbyshire
County Council website
and newer ones are emerging Alabama rot
Etc to name a few
this proposed changes of use for a few
dogs sorry it's not for a few local dogs
now and again it is a permanent change
of use
that one does not sit healthy
Agricultural and use in the valley
it is detrimental to Wildlife it sets
the president
if approved it is another truth in the
cogs turning in the decline of the Great
British Countryside thank you
thank you if you should remain where you
are are there any questions for the
speakers councilor Elliot
thank you Jen just a quick one yeah you
mentioned uh it used to be farm for hay
yes when was it lasted
last year okay local farmer yeah thank
you very much
foreign
thank you
you'd like to state your name and then
it's three minutes
you just state your name and then it's
three minutes when you're ready
Catherine barturus
okay
my name is Catherine Waters and I have
lived at little Chatsworth the property
above the field for over 45 years
it is a field effectively at the bottom
of my garden I would like to object to
this planning application for the
following reasons from a personal point
of view having only retired recently I
was looking forward to finally enjoying
my home and garden overlooking the
beautiful and peaceful Caldwell Valley
to be threatened therefore by the
prospect of the constant barking of
multiple dogs and their owners shouting
instructions that is extremely upsetting
the proposed change of use of the field
shows no regard to the effect this will
have on the residence of the Caldwell
Valley there's no local demand for this
there are currently over 50 footpaths
and 10 Bridle paths and many other
suitable locations in the home sale
Caldwell Valley where animals can make
exercise for such activity
when searching on W W dog parks near
me.co.uk there are two dog walking field
facilities within five miles of here and
18 within 25 miles among these existing
sites there is already a dog training
facility pause and play gun dots based
in legit homesfield a much more
appropriate and suitable site
and there is also one in milhouses but
Buster still training which having
looked at the addresses and the
supporters is surely more conveniently
placed for many of them especially the
supporting letters for members of the
Broadway Pet Shop Facebook group which
was one of the Facebook groups asking
for support for the applicant for this
proposal ironically if they were to use
the proposed field they would pass many
more suitable sites on the way there
under the government Provisions planning
reforms were severe to certain
guidelines if this is passed an example
of these guidelines not being adhered to
is that they must enable planning
decisions to be taken at the lowest
possible level with the involvement of
local people
I note that there are 71 registered
locals against the application and only
two in favor
the alleged over 75 out of 75 seven
supporters are not locals living in some
cases over 10 miles away in Hillsborough
or alfreton 17 miles away both of which
will involve round trips for single dogs
of over 40 miles no doubt powered by
diesel or petrol engines
almost a hundred percent of the locals
are opposed to this for all of the
reasons
which the local authorities obliged by
the government to take into account when
deciding upon such a proposal we do not
want or need this facility and it will
cause only harm to the Caldwell Valley
thank you thank you are there any
questions councilor Cooper
yeah good afternoon how close is your
property to the field please it's
directly above so so my garden goes on
to the entrance field
and my neighbors attached property
goes right onto the field
so so in so in terms of
meat Ridge how close is your property
though to how close is your property to
the field
well this my property the garden field
okay so so what's the what's the
distance between your property and the
field so I've got an idea how big the
garden is uh measure um
there are 50 feet
50 feet
okay all right all right thanks
thank you no other questions if you'd
like to take your seat
thank you thank you
our next speaker is Holly Botros
you just state your name and then it's
three minutes when you're ready
hi I'm Holly Stuart Bamford
if this proposal is allowed to go ahead
the impact on the area immediate
residence agricultural land Road users
Walkers cyclists and horse riders will
be substantial it will increase danger
traffic and noise to the area and be
detrimental to the Views and look of the
green belt from both sides of the valley
without someone constantly on site it is
impossible to maintain an effective
level of monitoring of numbers of people
cars dogs noise people leaving and
entering on time
this will also set to presidents of the
valley for future planning and is an
unnecessary addition which does not
benefit any locals there is also a large
worry that once change of use is gained
or training ideas and dog walkers could
be added and cars car parking areas and
dogs increased
also as the planning goes to the land
not the person future developments could
then happen more easily once change of
use is granted
the planning report in 6.20 states that
the applicant limit the number of dogs
to four per session this is the same
number as is suggested on the
applicant's website which states we walk
up to four dogs occasionally five at any
one time however when looking at the
applicant's social media she daily
uploads photos of her walking groups of
dogs of more like eight to ten which is
of great concern if the applicant isn't
consistent to her own rules I don't have
much faith in her monitoring and
limiting other people's numbers when
occasionally checking the site by CCTV a
one-site visit per day
I also note from the applicant social
media that her dog walks show dogs in
large groups in many different locations
nearly always off the lead this to me
shows that there isn't a shortage of
places to walk dogs off Leeds and that
she constantly does do this showing me
for such a vicinity is even less
required
this proposal offers no enhancement to
the area of green belt we are not in
need of such a business and I can't see
how it can offer local employment it
affects perceptual qualities such as
Tranquility as referred to in sdc3 of
the original planning statement it does
not as referred to in dc-12 as a
planning statement make a positive
contribution to the quality of the local
environment nor does it enhance the
quality and local identity of existing
communities and their surroundings it
has no positive effects on any of the
immediate or further afield surrounding
areas it is not as refer to also in SDC
12 protect the immunity of existing
occupiers and create a good quality of
immunity for future occupants of land or
buildings including in relation to
privacy overlooking overshadowing and or
any overbearing impact 30 seconds
remains I have personally spent a lot of
time speaking to a large number of
residents in and around Caldwell Valley
including all residents of Milford Lane
I can unequivocally say that not one
person I've spoken to either supports
this facility nor would use it the
general view is that this proposal will
do nothing other than harm the enjoyment
and Aesthetics of a beautiful area and
the lives of everyone who lives here
from every local aspect there is nothing
positive for Cordova Valley about the
proposed application
thank you are there any questions
counselor Hall
thank you good afternoon you sound
really knowledgeable about uh the actual
applicants uh so application so I'm just
going to ask you may not be able to
answer but when you talk about up to
four or even five dogs at a time is that
from one household then do you mean well
I'm talking about on her website she
states that she walks up to poor dogs
occasionally five at any one time
um to ensure that
um the dogs get looked after properly
um however when looking at photographs
and things on how social media actually
it has groups of more like eight to ten
so when uh when you're being told that
there's only games before dogs allowed
in the field at any one time which is
what it says in the planning report
um that doesn't really match with her
website
okay I just thought I'd ask
I mean I'll I'll ask the applicant
that's all because my concern is whether
before separate families or or dogs from
one family but I'll I'll ask her it's
okay thank you
any other questions thank you if you'd
like to take your seat
actually chair if the other speakers and
uh can now come in so if you could then
go back to the executive meeting room
that'd be very helpful thank you
foreign
thank you
good afternoon I'm going to take you in
order of the names that I've got written
down in front of me
so the first Speaker I have is Ashley
Turner if you'd like to take a seat
if you'd like to state your name and
then it's three minutes when you're
ready
I'm Ashley Turner local resident
ladies and gentlemen of the planning
committee
I submitted my opposition to this
application to the planning officers on
the 2nd of July last year and I would
like to underline and enlarge on My
Views to you the planning committee
I have three points of contention
a necessity unsuitability no local
benefit
and together these demonstrate there is
no justification
for further
violation of the green belt
a necessity
Parish of homesfield extends to four and
a half thousand acres second largest in
Derbyshire and has 62 footpaths and
bridalways which provide over 23 miles
of dog walking opportunity for everybody
further to the most further to that most
local residences have Gardens which can
be used for dog exercise and training
very few residents would have use for
this proposed facility as indicated by
the letters of support only two of the
77 supporters come from holmesfield
those that may want to use such a
facility I have ascertain that there are
at least 10 of those existing within 20
mile radius
there are two as close as Chesterfield
there is no requirement in a Home Shield
unsuitability
a repeat a statement I make regularly
nowadays and that is the corduro valley
is a very very special place
it has survived hundreds of years
of as an outstanding and relatively
unscarred example of traditional English
farming Countryside in case in a
spectacularly beautiful Valley
it's vital to our heritage
to protect such places that still remain
the insertion of the Gated compound into
this stunning environment an important
heritage site is next to sacrilege
and the intended change of use is
totally out of context within this
delicate environment
dogs in such numbers don't mix with Farm
livestock or horses
and they can miss they can seriously
disrupt wildlife
30 seconds remaining
Democratic problems and noise pollution
would be inevitable in my opinion none
of the attempt of mitigation can
possibly resolve these issues and indeed
nothing else could in rural areas
Tranquility is a benefit to take for
granted
and many come to enjoy it
how does how does this contend with 365
days a year of barking shouting and
whistling the corridor Valley is not a
suitable location
okay are there any questions
no thank you if you'd like to take a
seat
our next speaker is Nick Todd
you'd like to stake your name and it's
three minutes when you're ready
my name is Nicholas Todd I'm a retired
childhood surveyor and I live about a
mile and a half on the other side of the
valley
I would say that I can hear the hounds
when they're fed and they're two and a
half miles away in the same direction I
wrote and objected to this scheme in
2022 comments I made are still relevant
but various things have happened since
untrained dogs are presumably seen as a
threat to the top public has the
planning officer or the applicant shown
that there is a a danger to public how
many people are actually bitten in
public places so one wonders whether
facilities necessary however if it is
needed and it is perceived to be needed
why put the facility where owners have
to use their cars to take the dog to
train it surely councils
and the cities who are adopting
15-minute cities have a duty to Triumph
minimize private vehicle use
granting this permission flies in the
face of zero emissions
if there is a need which clearly the
applicants believe they should be
approaching the councils to set up
secure areas within local parks where
people can walk their dogs off the lead
this is actually a better way of
training the dog because it's more
likely to pay attention if it's had a
walk before it's trained it would
alleviate the car Journeys avoid causing
the neighbors losing privacy and being
subject to continuous noise pollution
from car banging dogs banging doors and
dogs and whistles
the houses adjacent and you've seen
Catherine have no back Gardens the whole
of their land is in front of the house
and in immediately adjacent to this
proposal
so rather than the planners have said
that there's no increase over and above
agricultural use agricultural use on
that side means that it's cut for hay
twice a year or occasionally somebody
takes a horse and leaves it for a few
days or a few sheep it's not every
single day all the time so it's rubbish
to say there's no increase in noise
I have from my own experience of
planning realized that an increase in
noise is minimal it's the the amount
it's allowed to be increased is minimal
especially when the the starting points
is zero
so the positions remain
I think this is a scam I think these
people are wanting to get approval for
animal husbandry on this site once
they've got that it leaves a loophole
open to apply for a residence on a site
where an animal husbandry is so I think
in the long term they're trying to get a
house on the site in the green belt
thank you are there any questions
no if you'd like to take a seat thank
you
the next speaker is Helen Geary
you'd like to state your name in three
minutes when you're ready
thank you good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen my name is Helen Geary I live
in millthorpe
um about half a mile away from the
proposed site I'm a dog owner a horse
owner and a horse rider
on behalf of over 40 local residents who
have registered today I'm speaking to
you the committee on their behalf in
order to save time and repetition with
the many strong objections to this
proposed application my points are as
follows
danger to the public has not been
assessed recent fatalities from dog
attacks have been put down by
Specialists to the fact that when dogs
are excited or released they adopt a
more aggressive nature human nature
sadly will result in games being left
open with noise and aggression from
these dogs being set free in a strange
environment resulting in danger to
children in adjoining properties walkers
on the road
and horses both ridden in the nearby
fields and stables in addition the deer
Gates proposed are not self-closing
all monitoring is by the applicant only
the CCTV coverage the enforcement of the
terms and conditions and the code of
conduct are to be managed only by the
applicants
this monitoring is not enforceable by
the council
whilst the amenda code of conduct dated
28th of February 2023 is comprehensive
and seeks to protect the local community
it is only as good as those that monitor
the use
the traffic figures do not reflect the
true pictures seen by residents on a
daily basis
after the approval intensification of
the use can take place as no conditions
proposed restrict the actual level of
activity
only four car parking spaces are
provided but there is no control
enforceable by the council to restrict
the number of or types of vehicles using
this site
the only control is
by the applicant
73 objections are from local people 75
of the 77 letters of support are from
people who have no Affinity with the
locality and will have little or no
regard for local residents those
visitors will not know the nature of
local traffic and the nature of the road
users
forthcoming changes to the planning
system
are that it should be community-led the
substantial weight of local opinion is
that even a trial period should not
should not be allowed this use is not in
the interests of our local community
whilst the trial period May ensure the
applicant sticks to the code of practice
during that two-year period after that
time councils are required to offer a
full planning permission rather than a
mere extension for a further period it
is at that time that problems occur when
the incentive to tow the line has gone
noise will travel across the valley in
this quite 30 seconds remain whilst no
Amplified noise is allowed barking dogs
and people shouting instructions cannot
be controlled and will out affect the
Tranquility especially in the early
mornings and evenings when the
background noises to its lowest the true
effect of noise issues has not been
portrayed or understood by the applicant
of the eho
this there is no control over pollution
which is enforceable by the council
daily monitoring and management for
cleanings again solely down to the
applicant through the code of conduct
this dog walking site is not wanted
needed under any circumstances by any of
the local residents
thank you thanks for your time if you
just wait there just in case there's any
questions you can't stop the Mark
I was not even are there any questions
no I think you're okay
our next speaker is more in Greenland
again if you'd like to state your name
in three minutes when you're ready
hello I'm Maureen Greenland I have some
sympathy for the owners of difficult
dogs but I don't think that a field in
millthorpe Lane is the place to solve
their problems
it's obvious that there's very strong
opposition to this scheme for many
different reasons including the barking
and shouting the lack of supervision the
detriment to the environment and also
the fear that the site could be further
developed in the future
these are all significant and valid
concerns
however my main worry is that the
proposed training field is in the wrong
place
at the best of times it's not easy to
drive up or down millthorpe Lane
it's narrow it's bendy and it's
dangerous in places there are always
some motorists who drive too fast down
the lane
or in the middle of the road around the
bends
every hour a bus goes up and another
comes down
as well as cars and vans there are
tractors and other farm machinery
if you happen to meet horses or one of
these large Vehicles you have to react
quickly to avoid an accident
at the top of millthorpe Lane there's a
notoriously dangerous Junction with
cartilage Lane there have been several
accidents and many near-misses on that
sharp Bend in recent years
any increase in traffic caused by this
proposal would just make matters worse
the field in question lies between two
blind bends in the lane
to have cars slowing down to look for
the entrance and later popping back out
into the gate from the Gateway in onto
the road would add another hazard
also
with nobody there to supervise any
confusion over arrivals and departures
or parking or even trouble with the gate
could lead to congestion that could
spill out onto the road
the development plan statement says that
the scheme would be quote
a new community facility to address a
need within the local area unquote
it's clear that there isn't a need in
this area
and there would be no benefit to the
local community
the opposite in fact
I suggest that this plan should be given
more thought and carried out in a more
30 seconds remain thank you
thank you are there any questions
now if you'd like to take a seat thank
you
and our next speaker is Sarah Nash
I'd like to state your name in three
minutes when you're ready
good afternoon I'm Sarah Nash
in March 22 the planning application
biodiversity report said there was
minimal bird lives seen at the time of
the visit but said it is clear that the
boundary trees and shrub vegetation will
form a significant habitat for nesting
Birds small mammals and for bat foraging
in October 22 the ecology report said a
total of just two species of birds were
observed wood pigeon and Buzzard both of
these are species of low conservation
concern on the rspb green list the
grassland field lack nesting
opportunities for birds as it was open
field used for grazing and mowing regime
contrary to these reports this field is
actually grass Meadow not grazed and
only mowed once a year by a local Farmer
for hailage we own adjoining land and
know this field has been left fallow for
a number of years providing an ideal
grassland Meadow habitat for a large
number of birds bats mammals insects and
pollinators
this Meadow along with other surrounding
Fields is normally cut once in late
summer providing undisturbed habitat for
wildlife and allowing grass and other
plants to reset naturally
we cannot simply dismiss the impact on
wildlife and loss of habitat caused by
land development in fact the latest rspb
listing shows a number of birds that
were on the green list are now on the
Amber or red list primarily due to
agricultural land development resulting
in loss of suitable habitat
this grassland and boundaries provide
ideal habitat for many birds of high
conservation concern including torniel
Sparrow Hall Kestrel yellowhammer field
Fair all of which are seen in the area
throughout the year
barn owls rest in buildings adjacent to
this field and are regularly seen
hunting across this area
we live in a conservation area at
cartilage and strive to uphold the legal
and moral requirements to protect and
support flora and fauna our aim is to
protect and promote Wildlife by managing
the various natural habitats on our land
and thus the surrounding area
the development of this field into a dog
exercise compound even with codes of
conduct for dog owners will adversely
affect the wildlife populations in this
grassland Meadow and surrounding fields
this development may be viewed as just
another field but our Wildlife is under
increasing pressure caused primarily 30
seconds remained
we own dogs ourselves and do understand
that some dog owners may have a need for
an exercise compound but this must not
be at the expense of our already
beleaguered wildlife
thank you thank you are there any
questions
no if you'd like to take a seat that
simply thank you
our next speaker is the applicant
Harriet Wordsworth
if you'd like to state your name three
minutes when you're ready
good afternoon everyone my name's
Harriet Wordsworth
I understand that the concept of a
secure dog field will be new to some
people and unfortunately there seems to
have been some false speculation which
has caused some reservations with
residents
there are many secure dog Fields
operating around the country which
provides safe controlled environments
for people to exercise their dogs with
field owners working alongside local
communities to ensure they're not
disruptive
this is not a free-for-all dog park it's
a private field that individuals can
hire on an exclusive basis to walk and
train their dog
most dog owners will want focused
one-to-one time with their pets
there will not be multiple dogs and
owners using the space at the same time
the field is naturally secluded with
Hedges and trees along the boundaries
providing an environment which reduces
triggers that may cause dogs to bark
the proposed planting of trees will not
only enhance this but help to increase
biod of diversity and create a more
natural environment
I agree with the officer's report in
section 6.33
that the use is unlikely to create any
more noise than the activity of walking
dogs in the countryside using public
foot paths
I am personally committed to being a
good neighbor and wish to support the
local community at the same time it's
providing an important safe space for
dog owners
I have built up a successful dog walking
business over the last six six and a
half years this has been based on people
putting their trust in me and I will do
everything I can to maintain my good
reputation with something that has been
a dream of mine for a long time
I will be very mindful of who I allow to
use the field this is my land and I want
it to be respected and well cared for
the same goes for the surrounding
environment
I will have clear rules for field users
I will meet everybody personally and
talk through the code of conduct at
their induction
anyone found to not be adhering to the
code of conduct will no longer be
permitted to use the field and I hope
that residents will come to me with any
issues so that I can deal with them
swiftly and appropriately
the people using the field will be
investing time and paying good money
toward their own dog
they'll be responsible dog owners
looking to enhance their dog's
well-being
I expect people to have 30 seconds
remain experiences in a beautiful
environment to be respectful of it and
the neighbors
if only two years permission is
initially granted this will present a
significant financial risk for me due to
the high startup costs but it is a risk
that I'm willing to take because I'm
confident that once the field is up and
running the local community will see
that it's a low impact asset to the area
thank you
thank you are there any questions
councilor Liggett and councilor Cooper
yeah
um your dog you're a dog walker yes how
many dogs do you exercise at once
um for my dog walking business we do
take up to eight dogs which is what
we're insured for
um that will be separate this job for
your business because they're this
this field will only allow for dogs at a
time so you could be taking four dogs at
a time
it could be I probably won't but it's
more for individuals to hire for them to
take their doctor they could be from
different houses basically different
people's dogs
yes so say a friend might want to meet
another friend with their dog at the
field no I meant you personally oh so if
you take four dogs are they all from the
same house or are they no with my dog
walking clients they
generally are from different houses and
how often do you propose to mow the
field
um
well actually I'm hoping to
during the summer months when it'll need
mowing a bit more often I'm hoping to
keep some longer grass because dogs like
to sniff and explore they love actually
running in Long Grass so I'm hoping to
have sections of different lengths of
grass at different times and kind of
rotate the mowing
um so that it's not mowed
say fortnightly through the summer
all over so so some areas could be about
Fortnight I think some areas shorter
grass yes okay thank you
Council Cooper
thank you chair a couple of questions
please if I may
um is it anticipating that at some point
either the the people bringing the dogs
or yourself will hire
um professional dog trainers
to be part of this exercise yep I would
welcome people to bring
um a trainer with them if that's what
they want to do all they ask in the code
of conduct is that they let me know
beforehand
um so I can make sure
that is appropriate and that they have
the right insurances and things like
that okay and um
dog foul and I know it's been an issue
raised
um what's the what's the plan around dog
fouling cleaning up collection
Etc we will have um a dog waste bin
which will be collected uh probably
weekly or fortnightly by a commercial
Waste Company
um so everybody will be encouraged to
pick up their own dog waste and either
leave it in the bin or take it home with
them
um I'll be checking the fields daily to
make sure that waste is picked up
um
but yeah it's just the same as anywhere
walking in the countryside
there will probably be some people that
leave it unfortunately
um but that's something that I'll have
to keep an eye on and if people keep
abusing that then they won't be
permitted to use the things
um
you've obviously got some experience
with this and you've said it's the dream
of yours Etc uh and obviously there's a
financial implication for yourself yeah
how many people do you expect will use
this over a year
this facility how many people do you
expect will use this over a year to make
the financially viable for yourself
um
that's a good question
with my dog walking business I have a
lot of loyal clients and they're all
dogs that I walk regularly we don't have
any really ad-hoc dogs and I'm kind of
hoping with this business would be the
same that we get regular clients coming
at least once a week
um
and I'll get to know them personally and
I want to avoid new people and people
coming infrequently I want to get to
know the people that are using it
um with the we'll only be operational
during daylight hours so it will vary
through
um the year as to how many clients how
many dogs are coming
um so it's hard to kind of say
um I think during the summer months
there'll be 13 field sessions per day
and during the winter there'll be eight
field sessions per day that that doesn't
necessarily mean they'll be fully booked
I hope that helps
yeah
thank God
thanks Chet um just a couple of brief
ones for me the link to be honest
um you say you're Keen to work with the
local community and obviously we've
heard that there's a fair bit of
resistance what have you actually done
to work with them so far to kind of
develop its various
um difficult because I haven't wanted to
in the planning process any of
um
they'd want to
haven't wanted to
please
so it has quite difficult to stand back
let people jump to the wrong conclusion
about things
and
leave the the residents that by the
fields and declare signals as well
um so yeah I know there's been a lot of
involves kind of information spread
around the community
um through letters and door-to-door
speaking things so it has been difficult
for me to step back and not get involved
in that
um
but yeah there's not been a lot that I
could have done really right and and I
mean well while we've been sat here I've
been kind of struggling notes people
have said said things that they would
even suggest as improvements even though
they were sort of anti-in so would you
be kind of open to having those
dialogues with them and things like Soul
closing dates at uh Gates if it were to
actually go of course yeah yeah
and hope that people would come to me
with suggestions
thank you good afternoon just a few
questions and points when when you say
it's going to be the field is going to
be rented out how long a period do
people rent each Breezy Park one hour is
it eight hours
uh is it split into our two sessions
uh there's a few points I'll ask them
together if you don't mind please I mean
you say about training
if you're not providing the training
it's all lying on someone on
[Music]
welcome to
bring the
link
oh I mean
yo
you have to excuse
I'll get drum field and I've been around
this area
something running I do quite a bit of
exercise
another couple of points I was going to
ask
is about when you say up to four dogs
but if they're not from the same
family if the total Street like
strangers then what could what are you
to stop dogs
attacking each other in a way I mean
people talk about Wildlife being
attacked but if dogs could try attacking
each other uh the other point is when
you say about noise I I do have to
disagree on you when you say the noise
of this would be the same as somebody
taking a dog for a walk in the open
Countryside I have to agree I'm sorry to
say because
somebody walking past your house within
a few minutes even if the dog is barking
with a few minutes it's gone I don't
know how many days this is going to
operate if it's seven days a week then
you've got dogs barking you've got
members of the public scouting or
calling adults whistle blowing it's not
the song
Countryside my
yeah
well as the same worldly dog owner and
it seems strange
got a question not just an observation
oh
sorry a question well
that's okay I can talk through those
points if you like but you might want to
remind me the question is I mean the
question is is really I was just picking
up a few points
right
how many hours is it going to be rented
out to a person and how many days a week
will it be used then thank you okay I
think also your first question was about
how long were the field sessions
during the day
um so you will start on the hour and
they'll be for 50 50 minutes long which
will leave 10 minutes in between
um people coming and going so that
hopefully there's no crossover if there
is a crossover that's why we've
Incorporated another hard standing area
for them as a waiting or turning area
for people to leave
um
the operational hours will vary during
summer and winter months because of the
daylight hours so
um I think there's 13 days that I was
sorry during the winter months and eight
hours during the summer months with
varying kind of hours as the daylight
gets longer
um
what else did you ask me sorry
it'll be seven days a week
thank you chair and I've got a few
questions just so that I can understand
new business model
uh-huh
[Music]
run this top position too and it's it's
going to take people a lot of traveling
to get to uh so he's going to have a
Countryside
is there a requirement for this activity
in in the UK
um I'm not aware of it anywhere else
and have you tested the market because
she seemed a little unsure of how many
people you're gonna get using the site
she's looking for some land about four
or five years ago
um and it's it's quite difficult to find
land that's actually for sale
um
but also that meets the requirements
I was want needed a piece of land that
could be accessed from the road directly
without kind of
they're being
people around um
so
um I did I think
tried on three or four other
um
locations and
various reasons they weren't suitable
um so for when when this piece of land
came up for sale uh
in 2008 1
um that's when I started looking into it
and realized that actually it was really
suitable because it's nice and secluded
um
yeah and it seemed like it would work
even though there are two properties at
the top of the field there weren't any
kind of
surrounding it
um
so that is that even though I know there
has been a lot of opposition that is
one thing that I did consider that there
weren't many
many properties around
what was the next point
uh the next point was oh about people
surviving yes yes yeah okay
um
I brought the land I bought the fields
before I knew before obviously I'd put
the planning application in and before I
knew that there was going to be so much
opposition
um
but I really don't I think people have
got the wrong impression about what the
field is I think they think there's
going to be a lot more noise and
activity than there is and I think
that's why there's been so much
opposition
um secure dog Fields there are around a
thousand in the country
um all operating without any problems
um
and you can if you want to have a look
there's various websites like dog
walkingfields.co.uk
um which is a directory website you can
see how many there are on there
um so it's I know it is new
to some people
but a lot of people especially I've had
puppies or
dogs from rescue centers that need time
to spend training their dog in a secure
foreign
a lot of people
scared you know
it's for those old dogs that have had
operations or are in season they need a
private space to kind of exercise not
necessarily train but just to exercise
in their own space that's that's the
main reason for dog walking fields
yeah and the final point was around
testing the market as the market being
tested in that particular area
um
I know from
social media that there are always
people asking does anybody know if
there's a secure area where it can take
my dog
um I mean a lot of community groups
um
and that is just something that comes up
all the time
um especially for dogs like Greyhounds
and
um
dogs that are prone to
not have very good recall when they're
off the league like beagles and
um scent hounds
um so that is something that comes up
which I just generally see anyway
um but I did do a Facebook post just to
see kind of what the interests would be
and received over 100 emails of people
you know really desperate to find out
some more information
um
I once were open I'm not actually
thinking that I will need to advertise
um I will just contact the people that I
know are needing somewhere
um and again wanting to keep it like a
smaller group of regular customers
um so yeah I don't think I'll need to
advertise because there is so much
interest
thank you thank you chair
Council real magician councilor Joe
thank you chair
would you
um I take you're going to be training
dogs
I won't be personally training the dogs
it'll be up to the owners to practice
their training with their dog they may
they may wish to invite a trainer to
join them in the field so
dogs will be trained in that field
yes right uh
so when you train a dog
it isn't would you agree that it's not a
question of uh you have to repeat it
probably twice a day before the dog gets
it into its head of which way to do
which way to behave would you agree
uh no it depends on the Training Method
really a lot of people use clicker
training this these days
um if you go to puppy training classes
um
it said things are certainly repeated a
lot more than twice a day
um it
within a few minutes actually you're
only supposed to train them for a few
minutes at a time before giving them a
break and playing
um
otherwise it's just too much for them so
it just depends on the method really so
these people will obviously have to come
back two or three times than in the day
would you agree no not necessarily I
wouldn't expect them to but you just
said that you give them a break when I
train dogs
I do either end of the day
and it's worked quite nicely I think
that's just personal preference
well it's worked
thank you counselor Jones
and it's about business plan because I
think you'll be charging quite a good
amount for these people to get there but
50 minutes in yeah and they're coming a
long way a lot of them
and they're paying for a trainer
do you think they might start putting a
lot of pressure on you to provide the
facilities like if dogs were wandering
around that field every day and it's
been raining and they're coming back on
Monday will they be saying to you can we
have a little cleaning thing I didn't
stop like that to expect
something more for the money because I
think I would okay that's a good point
um a lot of a lot of dog walking fields
around the country do have lots of nice
facilities like that they'll have a
field shelter so that
um people can stand out of the rain
while their dog runs around personally
that's not something that I would want
anyway because I want them to be keeping
an eye on the dog at all times and
picking up their poo
um and yes some people do offer dog wash
facilities obstacles sensory Gardens and
initially in the early days that's what
I was hoping to offer
um
but I think it's just as important for
dogs to be able to sniff and enjoy their
environment
um
and obviously we've been taken into
consideration that's in the belt so
there won't be any structures or
um
obstacles or anything like that in the
field
in in a different place then that might
have been feasible but it's not
something that we're looking at
counselor
thank you Jeff
um while we're talking about the
facilities for the dogs what about
public convenience how are how long is
the field Hideout for by the hour by the
two hours by the morning
it's an hour with 50 so it's every every
hour there's a 50-minute session if
people want to book more than one
session they can do what about public
toilet for these people that there won't
be any toilets and people will be aware
of that before they come so that's up to
them
from sight any water on the side no they
will they will need to bring their own
water
thank you
are there any other questions
I actually had a council I'm jumping
before you actually have two for you um
area
can you tell me the distance that you
actually would have to travel to the
field
and the second question I have is you've
mentioned tree planting and it's in the
scheme now are these mature trees or are
they just going to be whips
okay
um I live about seven minutes away from
the field
um in indoor so just in Sheffield
um and the trees around the entrance
will be mature trees
um the hedging trees to
um the gaps that are in the hedging
um
has that actually been decided what kind
of How High they will be
um maybe we will need to
um find some more mature just just whips
based on what Claire was saying about
the or already established boundary
trees that are there maybe it is
something that we need to consider that
they'll be more mature
okay
councilor Hall
you have a question yes a question sorry
if I was boarding you earlier but I do
it was something else I was going to
pick up on and one of the things you
mentioned about this dog waste bins
being emptied once or twice a week now
by a Commercial contractor would there
be a potential for you to get them empty
more often I've just started quick on
drumfield Town Council website and it
said they empty their dog wave pins
twice a week on a Monday and Thursday
where you say you'd get yours emptied
once a week or once a fortnight is the
potential to get them emptied more
frequently I'm sure there is but I don't
think it will be necessary there'll be
not there won't be as anywhere near as
many dogs used in the field as they
would be a council then okay thank you
Australia
and so I'm uh I've got to be honest I
knew nothing about dog park and I'm a
dog owner as well never never come to me
I'm I'm trying to get into my own school
why I would pay to walk my dog
not with a trainer just to walk my dog
around a fenced field as opposed to
walking through the valley called at the
bottom or any of the footpaths between
cartilage and Milford lane or between
the Rutland and the Royal Oak you know
I'm just trying to work out why I would
pay to walk around the field as opposed
to yeah walking like most people do
where do you walk your four dogs a day
or whatever you walk we walk in public
spaces yes you've answered my question
really
the the purpose of being retained
um so going back to the other
gentleman's question about the fencing
it's six foot defensing with rabbit
netting around the bottom that's more to
keep the dogs contained rather than
Wildlife out so while you're talking
about six foot fencing sorry chair this
has just come to Milwaukee this has this
has been mentioned yeah so little
Chatsworth which is probably 15 meters
from that one of the boundaries of that
field do you think they're going to
appreciate a six six foot fence at the
bottom of their Garden where they had an
open Countryside view across the valley
um I think actually their properties are
about 55 meters from the boundary
um and then we've also left a 20 meter
buffer uh from the top of the boundary
of the field before the fencing starts
and it's not a solid fence it's wire
mesh stop fencing like you would find in
any Farmer's field yeah if you look
through the fence like that I'll agree
with you you can look through it look
down fence like that and the post tool
bag looks like a blank wall
um I don't think they would be able to
look down it to be honest because
um I I think we're getting into the
detail and I don't think that's probably
necessary and my point was about
building a fence next to someone who
lived there forever
and if you're setting in 15 meters away
again
is that 15 meters not going to be dead
land at your field is not going to be
used for yeah
which is what we
that's what we've proposed to have a
wildflower when we're doing that okay
thank you thank you thank you
no further questions thank you very much
if you'd like to take a seat and our
next speaker is the agent Martin seeden
you'd like to state your name and then
it's three years Martin saidden I'm the
agent for the application
so cheers members of the committee
I know this application was called in by
the local board member I've regards the
useful land within the green boat in
terms of its impact on the landscape
traffic and Noise
well this is a recreational use in the
green belt
Cara's been saying to keep the field and
Landscape open by locooking the car
parking near the road
other than fencing improving the access
and laying out the parking spaces no
building is proposed and I just to
reiterate on the point of the separation
from Little Chatsworth there's a 20
meter buffer zone between little
Chatsworth and the fencing
um and that's going to be a well well
climate and create some hard research so
they won't be fencing directly next to
Joe Chatsworth
um
an ecological phase been undertaken all
the existing trees and vegetation around
the site boundary will be retained and
it was pretty substantial uh major trees
and undergrowth
that will all be retained and protected
enhanced by additional tree and hedge
planting on the coast of the wildlife
metal habitats
uh there'll be some margin around the
edge of the site where the graphs were
left to go long would be outside the
fence outside the circular area
they are officers are concluded in their
reports that the use is appropriate to
the character of the countryside
location and his appropriate development
in the green boat
the County Council is considered our
Highway Consultants report uh restricted
like traffic levels and access design
has no objections subject to conditions
the officers are satisfied under the
intensity of use of the site would not
generate a significant number of trips
to or from the site that would cause
under due pressure on local
infrastructure or cause highway safety
issues
a noise management plan has been
submitted which limits the number of
cars and dogs
but it's a one-hour session to one hour
session and prohibits the use of loud
training AIDS such as whittles
any users who don't abide by the slide
code of content rules will be banned by
the applicant and that's clear
environmental suggested a two-year
temporary permission
it does mean that the nearest residents
will have the opportunity to report any
issues while the field is in use this
should expect the officers have
concluded that subject conditions
proposed use would not lead to any
unacceptable harm the amenity levels
currently enjoyed by neighboring
occupiers thank you
thank you any questions
no councilor Elliot oh it's a question
always a question then talking about the
monitoring and supervision over this
two-year period who will be doing it
a lot of the applicants on the uh
Records cuts of who's actually using the
field how long does it how many cars are
involved
silver
the
evidence supposed to be there
under CCTV monitoring as well on the
gate so thank you you've also mentioned
an ecology report who performed that
um it was not
something
[Music]
thank you
you can
um again I'd like this part of our
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any points that you're sure
once we've done this
this weekend
have a discussion of the attrition based
on the herd read a grateful if you're
not with any at this stage and wait till
we've had a chance to make our
assessments thank you uh councilor
lickett
yeah a couple of questions
um for Adrian I would imagine
um will this site study US Open feels
like when it's true
and if
foreign
the
time
I'm correcting generous that how to
report it
by the
um County Council as part of their work
on the areas of multiple environmental
sensitivity work that they did which is
Allied to landscape character and
Countryside yeah Countryside character I
guess the value of the countryside so
it's part of their studying as I say set
out paragraph 6.15 in the officer report
in respect of that
do we have a lot of those sites in our
area
the areas of multiple environmental
sensitivity yes there's there's primary
areas and secondary areas and it does
cover a significant amount of the
district
the planned stroke map of that if
members are interested is set out in
your local plan so you can have a look
at that if you wish one of the
appendices at the the back
elster Clough
thank you chair uh Adrian I'm just
curious
um
I've been talking about the nice
mitigation
there's going to be a change of little
park for parking spaces
there's going to be a changeover every
50 minutes
there's going to be allowed up to four
dogs for each session so that so over an
eight hour period that is a lot of dogs
well I can't get into my head is why
there is not going to be any more noise
impacts in that area when there's
significant increase in traffic and dog
activity
I don't think I would would seek to say
to members that there wouldn't be an
increase in in noise it's whether that
increasing noise or activity is in
planning terms overriding and harmful
and that's the assessment that we've
sought to Undertakers officers and on
the basis of the advice we received from
environmental health colleagues the
terms and conditions of use the code of
conduct and the noise management which
the
permission if it were granted would be
subject to the advice is from
environmental health officers that in
their opinion that's likely to be
acceptable but that's why they recommend
the temporary two-year consent to allow
that to be tested in reality so that it
gives the opportunity for the applicant
to operate the site in accordance with a
stated objectives and the code of
conduct Etc and allows local planning
authority to monitor that so if it
wasn't being undertaken in an acceptable
way in accordance with those terms The
Authority has the opportunity at the end
of the two-year period to reassess the
whole matron and one of the speakers did
rightly say that the The Next Step would
be to Grant a full planning permission
or not it wouldn't be normally a you can
have another temperate mission that
another temporary admission it would be
a two-year
is the use acceptable during that time
do we receive
um loads of objections and loads of
complaints about how the site is being
operated it gives the local planning
Authority the opportunity of having that
temporary control over the use and not
permitting a permanent use to exactly
test that so I'm not
sitting here and saying there wouldn't
be an increase in activity and there's
bound to be an increasing noise doors
closing chat and dogs barking I don't
think I would receive to say that
wouldn't happen but it's whether that
activity and that noise levels is
acceptable in planning terms or not and
that's the assessment that you will need
to make as a committee and that's the
assessment that we've undertaken as
planning offices in conjunction with
environmental health colleagues and our
view is that it wouldn't but
the two-year period will allow that
control to remain
I hope that that answers the question
yeah I think
with is there's going to be room for
four parking spaces but we're only
talking about uh one Family household
with allowed odds for dogs and then
change over so I would have expected to
only see two parking spaces not four
um so for me it's slightly confusing the
information that we've heard up to now
and the fact that there's gonna they're
gonna need four parking spaces uh and
that is going to be detrimental to the
noise pollution and environmental
pollution in that area
first of all in terms of the the noise
and activity at reiterate what I said a
few minutes ago you will need to take a
view on that based on what you've heard
and what you've read and what the
discussion has been around if you were
concerned particularly about four car
parking spaces rather than two and
you've heard the applicant say that is
to avoid any at the changeover times
where there may be duplication space for
that
and you wanted to Grant a temporary
permission or for permission or whatever
you would want on the back of only
providing two spaces that would be open
to you that could be controlled through
condition if that was a particular
concern of yours but it may then lead to
the potential for people turning up
early or turning your blood light you
need to to go somewhere and that may
lead to some on-road Park intentionally
and that's what the the plan that the
applicant submitted seeks to ensure is
avoided
thank you Adrian thank you chair
councilman Cooper then Council Hancock
thank you chair quite a simple engine uh
when I asked a question earlier I was
told that the property was about 50 feet
away
since I've heard 55 meters
um in the report it says 55 meters
presuming that's correct
just just in terms of the measurements
share the distance from Little
Chatsworth the main facade of little
chats with Cottages to the north to the
application boundary is approximately
probably 45 meters but then there's the
set off within the site that you had
discussed where there would be a further
area Beyond which the fencing would be
erected and between the two what is
projected in the longer term to be wild
Wildflower Meadow the the issue that
we've had in discussions as officers
with the applicant and her agent is that
the
full-blown Landscaping schemes Etc bring
with them additional cost and investment
so that's why at this point
the there's a limited amount of tree
planting proposed because if after the
end of the two-year period the consent
wasn't renewed there would have been a
lot of investment from the applicant in
that time
you saw at the start there was a slide
that we showed that showed the fencing
in from the the boundary so that it's
taken into account from that the the
measurements in the report I would
obviously stand by when they they're in
respect of the facade of the property to
the north the distance from the
outbuilding to the site boundary and
then the property further to the south
west but that is a field Beyond
the application site I hope that's
helpful thank you and thank you chair
yes
thanks chair Council Coopers just asked
one of mine there yeah a couple of
others though um in terms of
what con because obviously I'm always
dubious about putting conditions that
are unenforceable under these things
could we kind of put things like
self-closeing gate
um I know one person who spoke raised
concerns regarding potential health
risks could we
um from the best dog diseases and
toxicity that go around could we put
anything in in conditions with regard to
a maintenance of making sure the ground
is properly treated
um so that such things go on there
um and second one is actually I don't
know whether it's really a point of
order or a question for the government's
officers are we no longer to advising
people that there shouldn't be
repetition because we were having lots
of the same points made again and again
yeah yeah
just in terms of the conditions if I may
as cancer Hancock's raised the issue
if you are
it is open to you if you are
happy for the development to take place
but subject to those conditions it's hap
you are encouraged to do that rather
than to refuse the application and then
we can sound cause nodding so I'm sure
appreciates that my view on the two
specifics that you've raised are that
you could
require and enforce a self-closing gate
if you felt that was absolutely
necessary for the development to go
ahead that could be enforced because
it's it's in situ and it's a is it there
or isn't it there does it work or
doesn't it there in terms of the
toxicity of the land I would be reticent
about doing that because I would ask
whether that's actually needed to make
the development acceptable and I'm not
sure I think it is and in terms of
enforceability it's going to be very
cool for us to to monitor that on a on a
day-to-day basis and to achieve what end
um so I actually I'd be concerned about
imposing that condition
and in terms of the self-closing date if
you've held it was essential to go ahead
then um you could impose that but again
I would would ask is a self-closing gate
absolutely essential to allow the
developer to go ahead in in some form
of people that helps
Council Armitage
thank you
as far as I'm concerned
you but
the nail on it because she said
the feel at the moment's in the green
belt and if planning permission is it
reverts to a Brownfield uh sign and
surely this is uh completely against
ss10 of the uh log plan
we've set out in the report share the
the issues regarding ss10 and and
concluded accordingly in terms of how it
sets up against the the green belt
policies that needs to be your your
first assessment of course and similar
considerations take place when you
consider an equine developed in the
green belt so you'd have some similar
concerns and considerations just relate
to that but
um in terms of of this application you
should determine this application on its
merits rather than be concerned about
what may happen down the line
no I'm I'm referring to the policy which
we won't do it here to
I'm not I feel that you've not uh you've
gone down uh it's going to be turned
into a Brownfield side which if it was
an industrial site you soon
and that's a brownfields
and I'll try and help members chair if
there's some misunderstanding of the
reasoning set out in the officer report
out I believe we've gone through the
various planning issues and planning
considerations in order and we've
assessed the application against the the
council's Greenbelt policy and that's
what members need to do and in terms of
an officer opinion it's the view of
officers that it is in accordance with
the outdoor recreation policy it does
preserve openness and doesn't conflict
with the purposes of including land
within it so I'm I'm not clear what um
calcium is concerned about from that
point of view chair it can't preserve
openness when there's a a deer fence all
the way around how can that be open
that's the the consideration that you as
planning committee can lead to to
consider and come to a conclusion on
chair
counselor Elliot thank you chair thank
you I'm sorry to our upon about it but
I'm gonna I think that's probably one of
the best questions that Council Leggett
came up with uh I need some more
information now because I'm not sure I'm
getting what you're talking about either
because Council Armitage is brought it
up as well if this is green belt
and you'll give the permissions we give
for the applicant to run a dog business
there and it becomes Brownfield
surely at that point
unless it's conditioned differently they
can then apply to build something on it
and it'll be a downside easier to about
to build on Brownfield than it ever will
be in Greenbelt because we wouldn't go
for it
just just in terms of that sheriff and
it's the issue of it
becoming a previously developed site
then the issue that you would then need
to assess if there's an application
submitted at that point is whether the
develop then had a greater impact on
openness and purposes including land
within it so it doesn't necessarily then
follow that the use goes from an
agricultural use to a non-agricultural
use and therefore it becomes a site on
which any development can take place
Greenfield or Brownfield so I don't
believe that follows chair sorry Adrian
but I thought you just said once it
would move away from being an
agricultural side
it would it would lose that agricultural
use status it would become adult
training exercising site so it would no
longer have that agricultural use and
can it revert back to that agricultural
use or does it always then remain as a
Brownfield side
there's no Planet consent needed for
Agricultural Development whether that's
use of land for agriculture or any
Associated activity so it wouldn't need
permission to revert back to an
agricultural use
right and can it be conditioned that the
building never goes on that side because
I'm starting to worry I'm all for people
getting a business off the ground and
getting it to be more viable I don't
know viable that field needs to be it's
not something I don't believe we're
exploring in the planning committee but
at some point I am going to bring it
back up surely there needs to be some
conveniences some setup for people to
use a toilet facility on that side
yeah I'm
concerned in advising members here that
we're getting to a situation where
members are seeking to take a view on
development that isn't actually proposed
you need to remember and consider what's
actually being proposed not what may
happen you will have control over any
subsequent funding application that's
submitted for buildings other facilities
on the site you're being asked to
consider
on this application the change of use of
that site to a dog training exercising
area the provision of an altered access
car parking and turning area and the
construction of the fence that's what
you're being asked to consider is it
acceptable in planning terms or not
that's the decision you need to make in
terms of future development
I can't advise you what may or may not
come forward on the site there may never
be an application to provide any more
developed on the site there may be but
you will then need to judge that
application on its merits when that
sorry Adrian but I asked the I asked
this and the speakers about the oh sorry
of the applicant about public facilities
for for public convenience on that side
before I asked about Brownfield and
Greenbelt so surely if there's going to
be a facility there for dog training
call it what you made dog park or seven
eight nine ten hours a day probably
longer in the summer there should be
some facility there for people to use
and if that was the case then planning
application would need to be submitted
for it and it would need to be judged
and assessed on its Merit should that
not be in this application
it's not for the local planning
authority to what Constitution should be
part of an application you're not being
asked to consider other things other
than what is being proposed and at
emphasized to the members that you see
to that consideration not you think
should or possibly could go on the site
because I can't I can't advise you an
application may be submitted for a house
yeah I get I get all that Adrian uh and
I I'm I'm also got running around in me
and the the one that councilor Clough
came up with and that's for me for
stc-12 about protecting immunity of the
existing occupiers a little chats with
and so on and so forth up and down that
field under 78 people that are objecting
to it
thank you if there's no other questions
for
the officers we can move to the debate
so I will open the floor if anyone wants
to stop
counselor Leggett
well personally as an ex-verinary nurse
I'm going to agree with Roger
um about the dog fighting or is me
immensely
especially this 10 minute crossover
period
because not everybody is going to have
the intelligence to pull on it pulling
in with their car and keep their dog in
the car until the last people have put
their dog in their car and gone home
they're not the first thing that you're
gonna do is get there and open the call
um I'm very concerned about that
uh also noise from the mowing at the
moment it's mowing once or twice a year
by a tractor for hay
uh if we're talking you know ordinary
mowers possibly every two to three weeks
through the growing season that's quite
a lot more noise than that area's been
used to
um
what else I got uh access
that bothers me from looking at those
photographs when a tractor pulls in and
out of that field of tractors up there
the driver can see the car's down here
and I really don't think it looks like
you can see very far at all as you're
pulling out in a car through that with
those hedges
that's my opinions thank you
thank you uh yeah and the noise thing is
is for me as well even the applicant has
said that the you know a lot of dogs
there and they're going to be trained on
recall you can't tell me I shout for my
dog sometimes when he decides he's going
to be a belligerent little thing and I
know there will be a lot of shouting
going on in that world it's quite simple
and the gentleman who lives across the
valley says he can hear the hounds so
I'm always going to be hearing people
shouting across the valley as well on a
very still day
thank you chair
um I've got a number of concerns in a
number of areas
um I mean policy ss10
um
it says obviously there's no buildings
proposed but the engineering operations
that are not inappropriate providing
preserve an openness
it doesn't mean that at all we're
fencing in the area
and effectively we're putting in a
sandstorm gravel bed book paths so we're
changing the the Green Field completely
um another thing that concerns me again
is
there seems to be a little a lack of
planning here somewhere along the line
because we're talking about whips not
developed trees but then it's saying
that we can have developed trees if
that's what you want
um that wouldn't protect against nice
pollution the whips uh environmental
pollution from this travel
um
the uh the dog litter effectively uh
would would create more environmental
pollution and the trees would they
wouldn't be developed trees to absorb
all that pollution
and there's also a to me a danger with
horses next to this site
um
yes the gate could be left alone
you know it's going to be on camera
there's not going to be anybody there to
control everything
so there's a potential for dogs to get
out
on this horse and exhale
and turn already supported the six point
Watson SDC 12. I don't think it meets
that either uh that that really worries
me
um and that's all I've got at the moment
thank you
thanks chairs it's an interesting one
because in principle I actually don't
object to this at all I find a lot of
the objections that we've come in are
almost contradicting themselves on a lot
of occasions because the whole idea of
this area is that dogs have got free
roam in a safe space and to me that
actually is probably a lot safer than
alone than to throw more than thought
paths and potentially if you're worrying
animals anyways I think that that bit
becomes self-regulating
uh we've got people saying there's no
local demand and people won't travel
that far but then they're complaining
about potential increases to traffic
um and then uh I'm gonna try to do my
own handwriting on some of these uh
there was another one carried me on
handwriting I think we probably do if we
do proceed with it to address one of the
key concerns is to have is to put that
self-cl close engaged and get into the
thing and I'll apologize if I'm
misquoting because I've written it next
to her neighbor it may not be her I
think kind of picking up what what
Council Bluffs just said I've got um
Maureen Greenland who said it needs more
thought and I think that's kind of the
thing that's coming across to me I think
in principle it's not necessarily wrong
but there's too many intangibles here
and we're not hearing
it's kind of well we can do this we can
do that but actually that needs to be
what's important to this
um so I'm not opposed to it but I I
would be more inclined to say bring it
back again with some more detail
okay
so before we proceed any further I'll
ask the Clark to go through how we
address motions
thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that Amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officers recommendations then
the member who has moved the motion must
give the reasons for doing so
the reason for moving emotion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls in other words it
is not passed
that doesn't mean that the recognition
automatically approved
rather you will need to take a
conversation of function in favor of the
recommendations or a different course of
action this will need to be approved by
the committee through another vote
thank you chair
thank you
having heard and read everything before
us today
are now asking the view of the committee
on the application so I'm opening the
floor for a motion councilor Cooper
I'm gonna move off on that officer's
recommendations please chair can I
second that please
thank you
the clerk will now read out what the
motion is
okay chair the motion is to approve the
application in line with officer
recommendations uh and with of course
her usual practice uh the vote will be
taken by roll call
councilor Hancock chair would the
movement second to be prepared to accept
an amendment in regard to that
self-proving gate
yeah I'm okay with that
so approve officer recommendations with
the additional condition that a
self-glowing gate be installed
the essence of anything curvature wish
to add Adrian
no that's clear chair along with the the
introduction all right discuss term
prosecutive conditions 7 8 and 11 I
think he was
seven nine and ten I lose
councilor Armitage okay
councilor Clough
against
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
councilor Hall
we're going to
counselor Hancock for
councilor Lacy
councilor Liggett against
councilor Jones yes
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse or
a counselor
Roth against
that's for for the motion and eight
against the motionless Bollinger
thank you thank you everybody you are
now released
um it's not yet determined that motion
has fallen so the issue is now um is
there a further motion
sorry I do beg your partner I was
thinking of my cup of tea the motion was
Fallen have I got a second Motion in
I propose that we go against officers
recommendations councilor are you happy
to say thank you
Jim before you take the vote it would be
helpful to have some um Clarity on the
specific reasons for refusal charity
like including on any decision and if
it's appropriate and emotions
um
followed then I suggest that if you find
the word in that condition of those
reasons would be an association
consultation with yourself and the vice
chair yeah that's fine so just the
headlines at this point there would be
appropriate to me it's noise pollution
and concern of welfare
Council Bluff
I think also SDC 12 I don't it talks
about high quality design
um
I don't think there's been further
importance of this it's not high quality
design at all
um I don't think we meet that
uh also
ss10
um
defenses inside the boundary and it's
sunstorm parking area rather than Grass
Creek that's been talked about
um I don't think that keeps it as green
green area it really changes the area
thank you Chad I suppose the leader is
too that it's inappropriate for the
green belt
just in terms of um cancel it off and
yourself you said it suggests that that
those those issues the ones that
included that doesn't preserve the
opposite of the green melt by reason of
the structures and the the hard
surfacing that's proposed and the
comments and games associated with them
so the motion then shows essentially to
reject officer recommendations
um the issue about noise pollution was
raised as a concern and then also in
terms of the proposals do not preserve
the openness of the green belt is that
the essence of it members
nature although we're cutting out the
roll call councilor Armitage
councilor Clough
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
councilor Hall
or
councilor Hancock
councilor Lacey
councilor Liggett for
councilor Jones
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse against
councilor ruff
uh it's nine for the motion and three
against emotions pasture thank you now
you can go home for a cup of tea aren't
you lucky
and to the members we're going to have a
short break
Mr value you've been exceptionally
patient so thank you very much we will
be with you as shortly as we can
thank you
three
yeah the late reps were in the late reps
document that's in the pack
um this application is before me to high
events designed to mitigate noise from
Air Force heat pumps which were
installed at Akita swimming pool in 2021
yeah so heat pumps do not form part of
this application
the application site is located within
the center of eckington and the site is
outlined here in Orange
this is the red line plan
thank you
and this is the site like um located
sorry this is the location with the
eckington conservation area shown in
hatched yellow
the boundary of the conservation area at
this point is a close-boarded bench
the application is before me to hire
acoustic vents designed to reduce noise
from the air source heat pumps which
heat the site
the fence will be located on the
Southeastern corner of the building
events will be four meters in height and
constructed of anthracite gray metal
cladding and will replace an existing
smaller Timber close boarded fence it is
possible that glimpses of defense will
be visible from the conservation area
but due to its location officers of the
view that the fence will be read as part
of the existing utilitarian swimming
pool building and will therefore be
appropriate for the character of the
area and will not have a greater impact
on the views from the conservation area
than the existing building
the fence will be approximately five
meters from the boundary with the
neighbor one gospel Street which is
located to the east beyond the car park
access road as such it may be visible
from the garden however offices of the
view that due to the orientation to the
west of the garden and the height and
location of existing swimming pool
building the fence will not have more
harmful impact on light windows or
overshadowing than the existing
situation
following following are a selection of
photos from yesterday's site visit
this is taken from the south and shows
the existing fence
and you can also see the close board
Advanced boundary with one Gosford
Street
this is the view from gospel street
again you can see the fence which is the
boundary of one gospel Street and the
boundary with the Conservation Area
this
um shows a site in relation to one
gospel Street which is the building in
the middle there
and this is the view from the West on
gospel Street looking towards the
Conservation Area it is considered that
for the most part banks will be obscured
by the existing pool building
is considered that by virtue of its
location the design of the and
undesigned the fence meets the
requirements of policy ss7 and stc-12 it
also meets requirements of policy stc-5
by not having a harmful impact on their
joining Conservation Area as a
consequence opposites are of the view
the application should be approved
adding weights the above conclusion is
the opinion of the environmental health
team that advances appropriate
mitigation against the noise in these
circumstances
and that's the end of my presentation
thank you chair thank you I believe
we've got one speaker for this
application
thank you for your page
yes thank you
no thank you for allowing me to come on
today
you have three minutes when you're ready
my name is Paul vardy owner of property
of one gospel Road and have been a
resident since December 2011. the
property was selected due to the the
amenities it offered in the possible
development against it uh my daughter
obtaining a brain injury due to a road
traffic accident in 2010.
the national Leisure Center was no more
than road noise and at night nothing
noticeable due to the Leisure centers I
was at work
a gasified boiler can be heard however
this is non-environmental noise impact
to me and neither is the air unit which
was installed in 2018
I draw your attention to this planning
application because on the 24th of
January I submitted an application
requesting the noise impact survey which
was in further into the by the beginning
of the project the knowledge impact
survey we've done an assumption and and
led to this nice survey we carried it
carried out again
the noise survey which was received and
put onto the planning application
indicates background level noise uh on
on three occasions one assessment taken
on the 8th of October 2021 where the SLC
pumps was not there and two occasions on
26th of July 2022 and the 31st of
October 22. these noise surveys was
taken with ambient and not when the SLC
pumps was running when the SRC pumps was
running the indicated noise levels
within the compound was raising up to 74
decibels with a noise impact at my
property of 60 decibels hence hence the
fact that noise noise impact study uh
mentioning that this needs to be
resolved
I questioned this noise survey because
the first noise survey which was
undertaken on the 19th of January led to
assumption which has led to the council
then re-looking at this situation and
submitting plan application to amend
their original design
I believe the original design was not
submitted with plan application because
it was led to deceive me in the First on
inset due to the source heat pumps not
allowing planning application in the
offset
on the on the 6th of May I received
another
um application
what should I say friend of information
in relation to a nice survey and it
indicated that there was significant
adverse effects from the adversity from
The Source heat pumps which affected my
property
I do not believe that the TR the account
of the new survey takes into account
everything that can give you a
reasonable and fitting solution uh to
the SLC pumps the background noise
before the installation was 50 decibels
I want 50 decibels back at my property
and I don't believe this acoustic will
reduce the noise lower than 50 decibels
it is present without the SRC pumps on
I'm in question of Clark and Saunders
carrying out this survey
due to the fact that the first initial
survey again was done on assumption
and the latter survey was not conclusive
and the and the full information has not
been submitted that's time
okay
thank you are there any questions for
the speaker
no thank you very much Mr Bob
are there any questions for the officers
yes Jim just just got one and it's to
whoever's decided we're putting up for
me to high acoustic barrier
do you believe that that will stop the
Airborne Airborne travel over the top of
it
annoyed
um the fence has been designed to uh
alleviate the noise from the um from the
heat pumps uh our
environmental health officers have
confirmed that they believe that it will
work
um
so that's the advice that we've been
given from them and what happens if not
because
as far as I can see yes it will absorb
some sound is bound to it so it's an
absorptive material but surely it'll go
over four meters and just go I'm going
to stop making a noise when wind blows
um
get it right
um if if it's still causing a noise
nuisance then
um the
the noise would be dealt with under
um environmental health legislation
um but they are confident that this will
work but
um if it doesn't then then they will
have to go back and enforce against it
that way as I understand it thanks
councilor Cooper
thank you chair
um
it's going back to what Mr vardy said
Alice
um does this meet his criteria does it
meet and does it address the problems
that he is facing I I know
um Mr Varley said quite a little bit
there in three minutes I'm just trying
to trying to take all that in but there
is
so for his
um own good and his family is good does
this do the job and does it do it well
enough to satisfy Neighbors
I've been
told by our environmental health offices
that it will meet the requirements
legislation
just if I can add on to to that chair
that
um Alice and I are
following the advice of environmental
health officers the noise experts and we
are not noise experts I'm afraid so we
are following the advice of the
environmental health officers and
Alice is is absolutely correct the
advice is that this will do the job to
address the the noise issues that Mr
vardy and others may be experiencing or
beyond that we're not in a position to
to go beyond what the environmental
health officers are told that I'm afraid
it's a very specialist subject as
members will know so we're following
their their advice and we've written a
report entirely in accordance with that
are there any further questions
nope thank you and I'll ask the clock to
go through
where we go for or do we want a debate
first actually the point that would
usually a debate and then I'm looking at
the blank faces
shall we move to the motion if no debate
then motion so to match up for members
councilor Hall
I propose that we go with officer's
recommendation
thank you
so the motion is chair to approve
officer recommendations
Council Armitage
counselor Clough
councilor Cooper
counselor Elliot
councilor hall or counselor Hancock or
counselor Lacy
councilor Liggett
councilor Jones
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse or and councilor Roth
that's unanimous chair the motion has
passed
thank you all very much that was nice
and quick and sweet
but moving on to the next part of our
agenda whenever I can find my sheet
share just to
um advise you that um David Cunningham
the council's tree officer will take you
through the next report and David no
members have met him if it is just
behind me so I'll vacate the seat and
David all take my place
thank you
so relied some six which is the tree
preservation order TPO 192
42022 at wienerworth
over to David
thank you uh good afternoon good
afternoon committer this is for the
confirmation of true preservation order
292 which protects a mature Beach tree
and rectory Gardens uh it's All Saints
Church wingworth
um before deciding the order uh we have
to take accounts of any duly made
objections and representations uh to
objections have been received
um and it's the officer's recommendation
that we confirmed the preservation order
without modification
thank you you've all got notes in front
of you and I'd go to page 40 I'm just
trying to see this without my glasses 46
and
2.8 where it says the residents have
raised concerns because of damage to the
wall at some point this in fact wasn't
the beech tree it's a totally different
tree it was a u tree which is at the top
of the drive the beech tree is situated
further down the drive that's the lovely
picture of the beech tree in the
distance
so I just wanted to bring you to that to
your attention that
what is quoted there is not the tree
that we're talking about thank you
are there any questions for the officers
a lot of page turning going on
do we want to have a debate or do we
don't just to move straight to emotion
I'd move it to the motion that we keep
the tree
all in favor so is that to confirm
office recommendations and confirm the
order yes that's okay
thank you all very much
and that was a unanimous vote by
acclimation okay sure
moving on to um number eight planning
Appeals
over to Adrian
jazz is customary we've set out there
all the appeals lodged in the the past
four weeks approximately you can see
there's in a a number lodged with us
they'll be determining due course the
only appeal dismissed is the application
for the certificate of lawful use to
robincroft farm and I always say this to
members but it was a very interesting
appeal obviously
to take account in respect to stipulates
of lawful use and I again I always say
this I recommend readings and everybody
was in a spare 10 minutes that you've
got to well well set out and well
written and of used to you in your
decision making going forwards
thank you share
thank you are there any questions
regarding these
wonderful
um item nine I have no matters of
urgency but item 10 exclusion of the
public I move that the public be
excluded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following item on the
business to avoid the disclosure to them
or the exempt information as defined in
paragraphs through
partnership schedule 12 available act
the local government access to
information variation order 2008. if
we're all happy with that let's move to
item 11. excuse me sir can we just get
confirmation
um that the feeders um ended
Lucy